cette semaine aussi les sept plein de
très bon fils bon d'habitude ont des
salaires mais cette semaine une sortie
nationale
et nous donc qui est une adaptation
d'une pièce de théâtre qui raconte la
jeunesse de cyrano de bergerac
c'est très très drôle savoureux et ça
raconte vraiment l'histoire de
l'écriture de la pièce et c'est donc que
tous ceux qui s'intéressent à cyrano de
bergerac et ils sont nombreux
n'hésitez pas à venir découvrir ce film
dans nos salles et ensuite une petite
sélection de très bons films aussi que
vous proposons wild life avec jack
queyranne rhône qui est un très joli
film
la palme d'or du festival de cannes le
film chinois une affaire de famille en
vf et en vo je précise que nous
proposons aussi cette semaine
l'empereur de paris de jean françois
richet avec vincent cassel et abanda le
très joli film avec vincent lacoste qui
raconte l'histoire d'un jeune homme qui
vit sa vie jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient
confrontés à la mort de sa soeur et à
l'obligation de s'occuper de sa petite
nièce et je ne voulais pas finir sans
vous parler du phénomène actuel bohemian
rhapsody qu'il faut absolument venir
voir en salles nous l'avons toujours de
vous proposons en version originale et
version française
le film fait a déjà fait 4 millions
d'entrées et j'ai appris hier soir en
écoutant la radio que la bande originale
du film cartonnait aussi dans les bacs
des disquaires et
quinn est en tête des ventes de disques
c'est qui est une très bonne nouvelle
c'est grâce au film donc venez voir
l'histoire de ce grand chanteur et grand
artiste qu'était freddie mercury dans
nos salles cette semaine
[Musique]